[Music]
this film is current when it comes to
social media bullying a lot of the
things that are really happening in
today's society we really look at how
young people have come to a place now
that they start to lose their real
self-identity and they create this
identity in the social media world at
times you start to pursue that false
identity more than your own true
identity and in this story really tries
to teach you that real friendship is
much more important than the million
likes you get out there anonymous people
is that for you man crush Monday know I
have over a million ID followers I'm
gonna post this to show them the answer
that all still exist that's weird what
you realized humiliated within a real
word a lot of the film you see a lot of
the characters always on their phones
and I think that reflects teenagers
nowadays sometimes it becomes a little
dangerous because everyone knows what
you're doing at all times as much as
it's a great way to stay in touch with
your followers and family your friends
it also has this negative connotation
word you're not fully living in the
moment if you're so obsessed with
showing it to your friends and followers
the moments lost for you the world has
an opinion on how you look how you
behave I think has become so much more
exposed so bring you into the forefront
of a film is really really cool
[Music]
you
[Music]